we online there is it going
cool
okay um we'll just open the um hearing
for me open the hearing for submissions
in regard to the goal district council's
draft stormwater management bylaw
obviously we've got an agenda there that
has been
has been
published
and
first item on that agenda is apologies
so we have an apology from councillor
um dixon who
working through the two of us
and it's obviously come through she was
going to be sharing this and i've
subsequently stepped in to chair it
she's got some obviously some penny
issues
so
um
just move those apologies are
mothers aren't going accepted attend as
well
from what i understand we have
i can obviously see there's three three
sitting here in front of us um we have
two on
two
was it two on
um
zoom
and there's
two here
is it oh custom builds here
i thought they were
yeah so
is it changed
i've read the written submission as no
update on the
uh there's a further email saying that
you can't attend the email i can't send
the hearing okay
um i haven't just don't receive that
might be out there okay
right so it's been received this
afternoon is it
all right so
um
right so we're basically just moving to
the agenda uh working through the
submissions and the submitters that are
present and the first
on the agenda is
okay the chair recognises mr
keith havel
um
if you'd like to
document those
thank you
um i preface this by saying that as an
individual i want to be helpful to this
process and the content of the bylaw
um however due process must be followed
and i've got a series of procedural
issues one of which is significant and
two others and i'll deal with the the
initial one first and that relates to
input that you may be needing to receive
from staff
when is it going to occur and in what
format i would have expected a report
from staff prior to this hearing
considering matters raised in the
submissions and recommending changes to
the draft by law
it's highly likely that the staff at
council do not have the necessary
expertise to respond to all of the
matters raised in submissions
in that regard i would have expected the
council to have sought legal advice as
to the validity of various provisions in
the bylaw particularly in relation to
clause 51 amb
and clause 6 b and c i would have also
expected the council to have sought
comment from its planning consultant
with regard to various matters contained
in the draft some of which are more
appropriately dealt with in the review
of the district plan and some of which
are already subject to control in the
council subdivision and development by
law
it's a matter of natural justice
to be aware of any information and
advice being supplied to the committee
with the opportunity of any affected
submitter to respond to that information
and much of what i have to say in my
submission is something that does
require
comment from staff where do they sit
what recommendations
are they
making in my response to it
so as a result
either you hear from submitters today
and then seek reports at which point you
reconvene the hearing and allow feedback
on those reports
or you delay the hearing until all
relevant reports and recommendations
have been received
clearly the letter represents good
practice and is the most fair option to
those who have submitted
other submitters may also wish to
comment on this matter
and
given the absence of what i see as your
most experienced counsellor
counselor dixon
i also think that it is appropriate for
her to be here while she has an
opportunity of actually viewing the
recording of what happens here today she
does not have the opportunity of asking
questions and therefore she is limited
to the extent to which she can make a
decision on the matters that she sees is
important
i do have other procedural matters to
raise with regard to your determination
of submissions lodged in the length of
time available for submitters to speak
and i can speak to those now or later on
in your hands in that regard but the
point i have raised first is that of
most significance
thank you mr jovel
obviously i think
time-wise the other points that you wish
to raise should we have them raised now
as well so that they've put into the um
the minutes prior to seeking some advice
around decision
if you just push your button again sorry
yes
the second point relates to
deliberations on submissions
um the agenda is rather light in terms
of what happens here today it just says
um apologies and then um hear
submissions
the local government
official information and meetings act
allows considerations of submissions
with the public excluded under certain
conditions
in my view none of them apply in this
case
it's my intention to be present during
those deliberations
at the
meeting of um council of the 8th of
february it was resolved on the nation
of councillors davis and gardine the
councillors macphail grant and dixon be
appointed to the hearing panel to
consider submissions received to the
council's draft stormwater management
by-law
that does not provide for a delegation
for you to make decisions on submissions
rather you need to report back to full
council
and that would be something that would
be useful
being
explicit my point is however that any
deliberations that you may wish to make
in relation to this bylaw are matters
that need to be done in public and as i
said i would like to be present during
those deliberations
the third point i wish to make is in the
length of time to make a presentation
section 82 1d of the local government
official information and meetings act
i won't read out the whole thing
talks about a reasonable opportunity to
present views to the local authority in
a manner in form that's appropriate to
the preferences and needs of those
submitting
now to be given 10 minutes to talk about
six or seven different points in my view
is not reasonable nor is it appropriate
it will meet my preferences as to how
that is done nor does it provide
sufficient time
for for you to ask questions and for any
discussion
to take place as i said
i want to contribute positively to the
process and in effect assist the council
on having a robust and legally correct
bylaw
but
i would see that in my case that 30
minutes would be more appropriate to set
aside
uh thank you for those uh those
commentary and comments um
prior to deferring to
the ceo for advice is there any
obviously these other two submitters
present during that
discussion regarding the times
whether they should pass comment now or
whether they believe the sufficient time
to
10 minutes or 30 minutes
i was just seeing if they want to make
it like you indicated they may have
wanted to make a submission on any of
those
timings
just more of the fact that you believe
that it would have been longer than 10
minutes for the the time that's been
allocated as um you're
agreeing with what mr hove said around
the timings
well i wasn't sure we would be asked
questions
all right um i'm going to defer to a ceo
regarding um
the matters that have been raised there
sure thanks mr chairman
um look i'll try and cover these off uh
first key point to uh remember this is a
[Music]
hearing and a process conducted under
the local government
not the resource management act and
therefore some of the procedures you may
find in resource management don't
necessarily apply
so in terms of
the
timing of staff advice to the committee
this follows
entrenched practice of the council when
it comes to annual plan
ltp
and other matters where we allow
the people who make submissions to here
to to appear before the committee
without being restrained or influenced
or the committee being restrained or
influenced in any way
by staff reports
and about 10 years ago there was a very
strident
submitter who took umbrage at the
council putting forward staff reports uh
at ltp processing it was
and
the perception was that the staff were
unfairly trying to influence the council
before the council got to hear hear from
the submitters
so that is the customer practice is to
have submitters to come forward and
speak to their submissions raise points
and allow the panel or the council
whichever it may be
to
ask questions to develop their
understanding the process beyond this
hearing will be very much determined
upon the extent of the questions
uh raised and whether the advice that we
need to get
as mr hovel has said it possibly could
need advice from
the property group our consultants legal
advisors maybe
and also it may be that the panel
directs the staff to to actually
research issues so all those things
will be
advanced post this hearing
and in terms of whether submitters will
get the opportunity to submit further
that will be the preserve or the call of
the panel
normally
it doesn't apply under the local
government act it doesn't mean to say it
can't
what i can tell you is that certainly
all the the business of this
committee or subcommittee will be
conducted in public
so that when it comes to the
deliberation meeting uh which will no
most likely given correctly cited by mr
hovel the absence of a definitive
delegation
will result in probably a set of
recommendations going to the full
council
and both the construction of those
recommendations following the receipt of
staff and other external parties advice
that will be conducted in public
and so will the ultimate debate
can uh can when the council considers
those recommendations in due course so
that's that's that's
a point i want to emphasize um
so
in reality we're very early on in the
process the 10-minute speaking slots
again uh i wasn't involved but it's
it tends to be in the past customer
practice to have
uh 10 minute slots with the ability to
relax and allow someone with a more
lengthy submission or more points to
carry on outside the time frame
you can imagine if we had half an hour
speaking spot slots and two people
didn't turn up we'd be sitting here
admiring the decor for too long
so the chair has always got the ability
to allow people to to speak longer
there are some specific provisions in
the standing orders around delegations
and speaking time at council meetings
this doesn't apply to that
but the panel can really just make it
make it valuable at the time slot it
believes it should
uh important point all submitters is
that your submission has been read by
the panel and staff
and the most valuable use of time is to
talk to specific points and allow the
panel or the subcommittee to answer ask
questions to develop its understanding
of the issues and contention
so hopefully mr chuman that explains the
process
we're certainly
just stepping our way through this
and i don't believe at this point in
time there's anything that has been
put in place that
is
violates any particular law
but we have to be mindful and i
completely agree with mr hovel to be
fair to the process ensure that people
have
ample
opportunity to have input to be heard
and to be fairly considered
yes sir
thanks for that steve
okay um obviously in the situation we've
uh found ourselves in here
um as the chair
there's obviously just concerns around
the the um
time constraints and
the issues that have been highlighted
there but i think they have been duly
recorded
and uh are noted in the minutes
so it's my decision that we have uh the
relative people here that the
submissions are hurt and then we seek
advice
as outlined in regards to deliberations
and any other issue that's stated there
so we'll return to the gender
the agenda and i think that it's mr
hobel's submission that we're hearing
first
okay
thank you okay
so if we move from there to uh the
which is courtney i believe is it
just
trying to backtrack here a little bit
um
uh we can see you but um
i'm not sure is there technology
we we can see you quite and hear you
quite clearly
um
okay
the green light on our camera seems to
be going but i'm not sure whether that's
hey
yeah are you okay to um we've obviously
got uh
the
copies of your um submission there and
we can see you quite clearly quite happy
to present to myself and
and um councillor grant
thank you for
that
um
uh thank you courtney for that um i
believe there will be uh questions from
uh pres just so you know who's present
we have um three of the other submitters
that are on the agenda uh there's
councillor grant uh myself as chair um
matt bayless our uh manager uh water
assets
uh the ceo and i think we have another
uh just just so you know what room
that they
give you some sort of appearance of
what's there um i think that uh matt has
a question for you directly
thank you mr chairman
aye
courtney and thanks for your submission
um
and um yeah i guess um after reading
through your submission i think a lot of
the suggestions are really helpful
um but just in terms of my understanding
and the um panel's understanding
um
obviously we've had um quite a few
discussions around the
the
cultural contamination of wastewater um
but wondering if you can expand on that
and explain how that contaminant
cultural contamination relates to
stormwater and
differences or similarities to
the wastewater cultural contamination
and also
how you might treat that that
contamination
absolutely
okay right and so for everyone else's
benefit in the room i guess in
um in simple terms it means
um to remove those cultural contaminants
that the water needs to be treated via
land contact doesn't it that that sort
of
i guess is that you agree with it
yeah pretty much there are some other
little looking poles but for the
you know for
for clarity for today yes
that's the easiest way but also the
easiest way to treat cultural processes
to make sure things are culturally
positive in the first place
yeah so i guess could you could you
expand on that a wee bit and and
um
i'm keen to try and understand when
stormwater would become culturally
contaminated so for example as is roof
water culturally contaminated um or as
is runoff from a gravel hardstand area
contaminated when does it become
culturally
as contaminated storm water causes
damage to the
moly of the receiving water body
so
for an example if we have storm water
that's carrying a lot of uh
a lot of pollutants
for one way or another that then
enters pollutants into a water body then
that's culturally polluting it as well
as
ecologically
okay and uh just just one final question
is would you
um
assuming that we included that the
reference to cultural contamination in
the
in the bylaw would you see council staff
being able to assess that
um
or would we need to be talking to the
hokuni on every application do you think
there would be guidance that we could
use or something like that we need to be
referring back to you every time
okay thanks that
okay thanks courtney for that um
counselor grant you've got any questions
for it i'm quite happy with that
so we're satisfied we've clarified got
clarification around where that
the culture accepted okay
that's fine um
there's no other questions about now we
appreciate we've got the obviously the
documentation here courtney uh it's well
laid out and there's a lot of detail on
there um as we've stated uh earlier
just to reaffirm the fact that if there
were further questions or further
information required we would
the panel may
come back or we'll come back and may
have further questions or discussion
that we may want to
gain further details on so uh kia ora
and um
yeah
no that's fine thank you very much for
for attending today thank you courtney
next on our agenda
um
so the next one would be hw hwa group so
that is
sorry for the delay for the people on
the zoom there were just
working out a couple of late emails here
um and thank you to craig winslow who's
going to let us
win more time here and we'll have the
hwr
group um
present their submission
and that is
megan
megan
yeah sorry i'm jumping between a couple
of screens here
so yeah um where are we
yeah it's a cheer person uh richard
mcfarl here um so you can't see anything
either
right um did you hear the rundown that i
gave to courtney from the roonanga and
regard to who's prison in the room
okay okay um look we're all here
um
very common diseases
moving its
[Music]
[Music]
i think we all understand courtney so
yeah just do as good as you can
um
[Music]
support the bylaw in that respect
um
what they are really seeing is a bit
more certainty around
how this
will be implemented and they're also
concerned about
the potential for neighbouring sites run
off to
come across
their property holdings
and which has that would be held
responsible for anyone else that would
then
go to the storehold system which they
may not have been
responsible
in particular clause be an obvious
reader now it says there will be
sufficient capacity within the public
stormwater system provided that if the
capacity is not sufficient then the
public stormwater system must be
upgraded at the cost of the applicant
for an alternative solution sort
um i understand
and support as i've said the council's
needing to manage stormwater within the
current capacity limit
however i do agree with the regional
group's submission that the requirements
download properly
owners to undertake or update
upgrades to the public stormwater
management system
where there's not
sufficient capacity may result in
unreasonable costs for the
applicant or the development
for instance it is unlikely to be
economically visible to require the
developer to undertake an upgrade to the
public stormwater system which could
then benefit the wider
fundamentally not opposed to
contributing to an upgrade to stronghold
system
but what
clause
3.5 which talks about separation of
internal drainage
3.5 requires a full separation of
internal stormwater and wastewood drains
for an entire premises
when
in the situations for instance when a
minor
when a new building on a road area of 30
square meters or more is constructed
or if the footprint of the building has
increased by 20 square meters
or the impervious surfaces increase
the stop this drill could be usually
costly besides where buildings already
exist given that it will
legally be applied retrospectively to an
entire building site
and not just for any area or extension
and it's if you're aware
to carry out separation of existing art
networks such as this
it's a written group
it's concerned that a requirement
upgrade on-site storeholder management
may be imposed on sites where store
monitors charges are currently
acceptable
these upgrades should therefore only be
required where it's demonstrated that
the stormwater being discharged from or
properly does not achieve the prescribed
water quality standards
and the my understanding is that they
are set up in that real resource consent
held by the law district council for
their storeholder discharges so they can
send
district council by issue from
environment southland
and i also agree with this mentioned
made by mr harald's course which raised
concerns about the implementation of the
clause including how the council will be
made aware of changes to the
previous surfaces
and how cumulative changes
to impervious searches will be accounted
for
and also how reductions to impervious
surfaces
would be accounted for
so i definitely think this clause could
be admitted to provide more certainty
around that and again as i think you'll
hear
duplication
of processes here
section four of the draft
talks about site development and
management
and it states that the council may
require installation and maintenance of
private stormwater detention and or
treatment devices during the development
of property to [ __ ] or treat the flow
of stormwater
this clause does not indicate who would
pay for the installation and maintenance
of the storm or devices and
unfortunately it does not set out the
criteria for when stormwater management
infrastructure would be required under
this particular course
and this course
is included in the violence
to the council's existing subdivision
and development
mechanism for the council to require the
installation and maintenance of
private stormwater detention or
treatment devices
during the development of a property
then this should be made clear and
available
inherently it's not entirely clear what
that section or that section for it is
in endeavoring to achieve
which is the main reason for
would be implemented
and this uncertainty would be
detrimental to development in the
district
so yeah in my view i think this law
should be or ask further
clarification about the purpose or
objective of this particular course is
included
um
activities
clause 5.2 lists activities which can
only be taken on land with the prior
approval of the council
richard supports the inclusion of most
of these activities in this clause
however it does not
support some clause g which prevents any
changes to a property's impervious
surface without council approval
this clause applies to
the degree to which assignment may be
covered by premier services is typically
set out in a district manual in an
accident such a limit would require
resource consent
the intent of such rules is to
allow the council to manage stronger
flows from sites
the core district plan includes a side
coverage rule which limits slip degree
to which the site can be covered by
structures so it doesn't
actually cover that in previous years at
the moment and one of them just depends
on
the building coverage role
site coverage of a site
and this would set up the limitations
up to which a developer or land
landowner could develop their site
within public services
open about that they'll need resource
the rest has to be previous
then we can
certainly take layers and developers as
to
what they can expect from council
and when approval from the council would
be required
for still modern management purposes
uh that submission also discovered
draws 5.4 other restrictions and i think
that's really straightforward what the
submission was seeking there is
something to ensure that that provision
applied to construction works
and the solution included and some ways
to be included in that course
so let me know if you have any questions
on that
[Music]
doors see brothers any person from
obstructing an overlapping bypass or
floodplains with any material or
structures such as buildings fences
retaining walls
rock gardens etc without the private
mission of the council
this clause is supported
however i'm aware that there are many
cases with overland bypass will not be
known to landowners
and no relationship on any council
planning maps gis systems
the floodplains are mapped on the
council's planning match which is
extremely helpful
and it means that the community are made
aware of land and subject loving
a similar mapping system could be
provided with overland profiles so that
landowners and the community are aware
of where these important flow paths are
for management purposes
and can avoid
carrying out exercise effect prohibited
without any knowledge
um
section 7 responsibility
requirements around managing discharges
from neighboring properties
and it states no person should allow
the discharge or enabling
effectively discharges could originate
from a neighboring site then into the
receiving neighbours
want to system if the discharge if they
do not meet the necessary water quality
and quantity requirements the receiving
land owner may be penalized for a
discharge
overwatch it has no control or
responsibility for
this concern could be alleviated and
part of the mapping of the overlapping
overpass so that landowners are made
aware
of our process their own
in practice
hazardous um i think that's a fairly
straightforward submission point so i
won't
delve into that in any more detail
finally
additional comments which was at the end
of the richard rich submission
the richmond river is seeking further
information from the council about the
existing public stormwater system its
capacity in the flood events it's
designed to accommodate
the ribson group considers that the
evidence of flood monitoring and the
performance of the flood
of the system during nominated rain
events is required in order for the
council to carry out enforceable cost
benefit analysis of this bylaw
and this is often the
such as this submission process
direct summary
arising from roadways which may be
carried by the stormwater system
yeah
quantum private properties
so that so what we're seeing is little
clarity
in the bylaw about how the council
monitors
thanks megan sorry i think i called you
courtney before
um
just
the uh
fun of technology
um i'll just open uh open it up um
counselor grant any questions
no i think the set i think the
submissions for itself uh it was quite
self-explanatory and it is noted by the
panel um in regard to
uh under the item four with the
additional comments
around further information is sought by
the
submission that you've made there
around
the existing flows and over ground flow
monitoring
yeah there's a question from uh matt
bayless
thank you mr chairman um yeah and once
again thanks for your submission i think
there's a lot of good points in there um
and and some things that we can improve
um going back to your points about
clause 3.5 and the where where full
separation um of the internal stormwater
drainage um
will be required um just to answer one
of your questions there um
you said there is the intention to
reduce the
reduce the quantity of
wastewater in the
council's wastewater system
or improve the water quality so it is
it's to reduce the amount of stormwater
getting into our wastewater system
and that creates capacity issues based
both in our wastewater network and
at our wastewater treatment plant
but but going back to your points around
the the limits um
of of um when internal separation would
be required i guess um my thoughts are
that that would be that that that's i
guess a starting point um and
completely agree with you that there'll
be situations where it's it's not
practical and unfeasible and things like
that
um
but i'm just wondering your thoughts on
um
because i guess wherever we set those
limits that that
there's going to be situations where it
doesn't
um it's not feasible
um
but i guess that's why we've included a
dispensation clause under clause 13 and
that in those situations um the
applicant can
apply for a dispensation and explain why
they can't meet the separation
requirements
um
and and then it will be up to the
council to make to make an assessment or
council staff to make an assessment as
to whether that's reasonable or not
um
just wondering your thoughts on on that
dispensation process and whether that
would address your concerns
[Music]
[Music]
we're not really sure how this will be
implemented and
how much discretion the council will
have normally they'd be
would be working to set criteria
for stormwater quantity or policy
standards that would need to be achieved
something
is
okay uh thank you megan for your
submission um the points noted and
will be taken obviously
through for the
through to the panel deliberations
um thank you for your attendance today
thank you
and next on the agenda would be eastern
concrete
which will be craig
wilson
thank you very much for the opportunity
courtney's
valid point was at the end um in my mind
is the control of stormwater in a
flooding situation
which um
there's limitations
on referring to the south end of gore
where we have quite a few properties
involved and in the past flooding has
been an issue
um more to the point um a local creek
that discharges their stormwater into
the local
river
is probably causing the most concern
about this bylaw coming forward to where
we are today
i believe that there hasn't been enough
information
gathered
to
[Music]
simplify some of these bylaws um because
they're a wee bit cloudy because there's
not enough information
on what actually we're dealing with
i believe before we get to changing
bylaws a um a work committee
made up that would a
um be responsible of actually getting
two councils feedback and what they are
actually trying to
achieve with the new bottles
um it is getting run
it's getting handed down from
environment southland which in my mind
haven't been that helpful
to a local situation in the um
in our particular area of eastern
southern ghoul or mainly the gore
catchment
i've witnessed for 10 years what's
happening down at the bottom end of town
and
and
i've alluded that to the council and
we've
worked away with a couple of suggestions
and
we've done a scenario
on our own particular yacht
which is a good
average commercial site similar to the
hwa groups
and to your local trapless sites along
the
main road there
just to give you a couple of facts um
we've looked at some different voices
matt's been on board with us
and
i'm saying a particular
land footprint of one of our yards is an
average from the local area
from the recommendations from up north
to put a stormwater handling system in
that would be applicable to air area
of half gravel half seal
such forth
we are looking at a
cost of between 40 and 50 000
of
equipment
uh and water filtration
for an average
plus on top of that installation
so there's 25 odd plus so
you know for an average section down
there of
where these bylaws would actually take
us to for our own protection
that's the sort of money that
people could expect to look at
to
get to a water quality that
is
achievable to
go into the current system what we've
got
only
if the stormwater
um
of the lower part of gore is capable of
handling it
there's no point in passing bylaws in my
mind that can
penalize
penalizes
for
upgrading when the actual whole system
may not be capable of handling that
so i'd like to see a work committee and
actually analyzing what we've got
where we should be heading with
landowners and cancel drainage
hints on using the roads the roading
infrastructure
um
and the other
council involved environment southland
to come up with a slightly better and
more accurate
move to where we're heading because uh
megan
covered a lot of
things of stormwater coming from
neighbourhood properties onto airs
that maybe these bylaws could penalize
someone
um that
has no fault of their own of handling
um it also mentions about flooding that
no one has any control over but
the canceled drains are actually
backfilling and flooding our sections
which is a
environmental
um
situation which is out of everyone's
control
so
some of these bylaws are not that clear
as megan did point out
and that needs to be addressed
the stormwater discharge
of the lower part of gore the new air
fortner creek
um
needs to be improved but
there's no point improving one
particular part of the mechanism when
nothing else is going to
keep up with it and i'm referring to the
individual land owners or rate payers so
it's a group
achievement to come up with something
suitable um before we get to the stage
of
changing by laws
um
to achieve what we're all here to
improve our water quality
we need
look we need to look at better systems
better mechanics and what we've got i
think we all agree with that
and there's going to be a lot more
professional input of a
systems that work in other areas
and
the
town planning of the future of that
local area which there has
a lot of
empty sections that will be
improved on in some shape or form
and industrial use there's a lot of
industrial heading that way now
that um
in the future you're going to see a lot
more new buildings the sections have
been already built bought
so
before we get to in my point of view
before we get to changing bylaws i'd
like to see a bit more mechanics and
theory
and information gathered
of what we've got and how we can improve
on it
i only
very typically
wrote down a couple of things on my
submission
but
the
variable point of my submission is far
more important to me than
and some questions and some other
submissions clarifying a few of the
points of
some of those
um
proposed by-laws
i
think this
at this stage uh keith did
covered earlier on that um
we're probably
been underdone on time
to get better prepared for actual facts
with
um submissions
um
we've only had two or three months to
deal with people from the north island
coming down to give us some ideas and
stuff of handling stormwater
and i know the council probably hasn't
had
enough
input in its own infrastructure to come
up with a bit more clearing than what
we've got
already
yeah but once again thanks for the
opportunity thank you
thanks for submission there craig
um
before i open up for other questions
just um there's more a general question
around if you've been down there for 10
years the
the amount of water that's coming
through you know how you're saying from
other properties or other areas that are
vacant
increase decrease
like with the way our environment's
changing we're getting
once in a hundred year floods every few
years now um
have you seen that in the last decade
oh most definitely um and
as um
probably
uh there's more and more commercial
activity happening down there
um
and there's other things that are out of
control
of
or not out of control but there's other
things that
are not helping the issue but there's
more more traffic
coming into town
that's causing some small issues as well
but
the activity down there in the last 30
years has been four-fold i don't know
but
probably the roading number the roading
use of numbers would indicate
a massive change down that end
and
part of the infrastructure is not
handling that and
also the
the
owners of the infrastructure of
properties and stuff
um there's definitely room for
improvement there as well
what we've seen um
the new builds are getting better but to
be fair that there's a lot of and
for an i can give you example if we have
an empty section down there now and if
we go to cancel
and ask for a
stormwater discharge consent
um it is not clear
on
what is there's actually very little
information they can give us over the
counter
um
we've had
quite a few issues in that department in
the last five years with new builds
because everyone's in the
but um
well there just happens to be enough
information done
with
what's required and now there's water
quality to come on top and i think what
quality is as important as anything else
because we all want to improve our
stormwater discharge
but there's not a lot of information out
there of where
the quality is acceptable and when it's
not
i would challenge anybody to go and find
that particular
answer for me
at the moment we've got a photo
to say this is not good
but it's not acceptable
okay thanks for the commentary
dear craig
questions
for craig
um
obviously uh it's
matt's been
in the liaison with you through that
working group so
it's studio noted by the panel so no
thanks for your submission there craig
um we've got everything
here
so we'll move on to
the next one um
i'm not sure as
craig are we taking yours as red or
you're presenting yours craig
just clarify okay
okay
so that's craig for the record
from custom build engineering submission
okay and
let me move through to
is it keith
now for your submission thanks there
okay thank you mr jesus um
just while that's been going on i've
been having a read through the statement
of proposal
um that that went to council as a report
and i see that the abatement notice that
was issued by environment southland
required this council to prepare an
appropriate policy statement framework
ready for consultation
um
and no later than the 26th of january so
it's complied with that
it has prepared one for public
notification there is nothing there that
says that shalt have it completed within
three months
so you've got the flexibility of what
you do from here on in in terms of um
proper consideration in due
consideration of all the matters that
have been raised
now
my printer broke down today so i've got
a series of documents sitting on my
computer and i'm sorry but i'm going to
have to jump from
one to another i want to talk first
about clause 3.4
which is design constraints
and
it says that in effect that um
all stormwater systems must comply with
um will be designed constructed operate
and complied with a list of items
including this bylaw the subdivision
development bylaw
environment south and plan the district
plan the building et cetera et cetera
that applies in any case
and if you have it there sitting there
as a
provision in the bylaw
and something's contrary to say the
district plan then it's also contrary to
the bylaw which is a nonsense
you have a statement in the bylaw that
says you're required to comply with
these other documents and that's all you
need you don't need these
additional matters
the richardson group submission
also
referred
to that
and
i turn my mind to other bylaws that the
council may have
and again the subdivision land
development bylaw
has some
provisions in it that
refer to these other documents
and
that is worth looking at
but a more important issue was that the
design standards
for um stormwater are set out in the
subdivision bylaw
so why are they being duplicated in
another document
and that's part of the problem that
arises
when you copy the bylaw provisions from
another council and adopt them for your
own
now if you look at what some of these
other councils have do have done
they do not have a comprehensive
subdivision land development by law and
therefore they need to have provisions
somewhere and they put them in the
stormwater by-law you don't need to do
that because you've already got them
covered so in my view all the matters
that relate to design that you've got on
the bylaw are adequately covered already
you've heard discussion that in terms of
permeable surfaces
the consent is required if you extend
these and the proper mechanism to
control that is the district plan that
has appropriate um
processes for application objection and
appeal
i have reluctance to accept what would
be a qualitative decision from a staff
member and i'll come back to that
process
later
without a right of appeal there was a
right of objection to council but
the consideration should be dealt with
within the framework of better
legislation
namely the
subdivision land development by law or
the sorry in the case of permeable
surfaces the district plan
the point of discharge
which is section 9.1
does deal adequately with subdivision
things in the bylaw
the
point of discharge makes reference to
dual connections to the council's
infrastructure being prohibited that is
already dealt with in the by-law
and
it is a nonsense
um
no clarity would be achieved if the
current draft by law dealt only with
what goes into
the reticulated system
and you leave it to the other bylaws in
the district plan
to deal with the design and criteria
that apply
private systems should only be subject
to control by the gore district council
to the extent that they discharge into a
public system
the council in effect
by having controls relating to private
systems is
doing what is something doing something
that is the responsibility of
environment southland
it is only the public systems that the
council needs to
have controls relating to and those
controls in the case of a public system
say they'll shout not discharge into our
system
certain things and they should be the
things that come from private land or
anywhere there should be no difference
between the rules that apply in this
by-law or provisions in the bylaw to
discharges from private um
storm water systems or discharges from
land the effects are the same in terms
of the way they impact on on the
council's
discharge point
i recall
as as part of the um
public process for the subdivision and
development bylaw which was done in 2019
that consideration was given
to having controls in the district plan
in relation to
permeable surfaces
and at that time invercargill city was
going through a similar exercise and
they did include provisions
in the
district plan and it was put to one side
i think so the council could consider it
as part of the district plan later on
the local government act in in this
context also
under section 155 and i do recognize the
difference between the local government
act and the resource management act both
as to processes and
considerations but section 155 of the
local government act
um says that before commencing the
process of making a bylaw it should
determine whether a bylaw's the most
appropriate way of addressing the
perceived problem while i accept that a
by-law is the most appropriate way to
control what goes into a stormwater
system
i don't think it's the most appropriate
tool to control changes either to
imperial surfaces or
over the design issues
and in my view the council has not
considered this aspect
as envisaged by section 155 and for that
reason i suggest you need to seek
further advice from the planning
consultant and probably the law matters
as well
i'm also of the view that where council
has a subdivision name bylaw
adopted
it's not efficient and confuses issues
by having design standards in this
by-law as well
imagine the response you will get
if someone has gone through the resource
consent process for an intensive
development of say residential
development of a property
put in their building consent only to be
told they need a further approval under
the sub under the stormwater by law
it is an unnecessary duplication adds to
cost and it's not needed
rochester group also referred to
the
section 3.5 in terms of
separation of internal drainage
and
um consent is required where there's an
increase to imperval areas
but what if there is no increase
of discharges from the sites
the council's subdivision bylaw
has is one of its cornerstones the
premise that there should be no increase
from development of the amount of
stormwater that happens from from a site
there is no consideration given in this
bylaw to the potential for green
technology to actually manage and
minimize discharges from a site so there
if there is development
there is a potential under subdivision
by law for consideration to be given to
how can you actually reduce present
discharges from the site and that
provides an appropriate framework for
those things to be considered
invocable city
has some interesting
provisions that apply to that and also
to prohibited
activities
and
i want to turn to the prohibited
activities and
initially to
section 6.1
and that that says that you can't direct
a structure or stop back or um or
obstruct overland flow without the prior
permission of council
but they're a prohibited activity
and what does prohibited activity mean
and i make reference in my submission to
in resource management terms it's
something that uh for which no consent
can be lodged you know this isn't
resource management but it's local
government and act and i've had a look
at the case law that applies to
prohibited activity under the local
government act and actually can't find
any
um so the dictionary definition applies
and prohibited activity clearly under a
dictionary definition is something that
shall not happen there is no scope for
it to happen you cannot ask council for
a dispensation for it to happen
if you want to provide a dispensation
for something to happen include it in
the list of activities that you're going
to control
don't take the position of saying it's
prohibited but you confuse the heebie
jeebies out of people by doing it and
it's not good practice
environment south and in its submission
suggest deleting the section on
dispensations
and having considered what they said and
having had to think through i think
they're right
i think that you should have a section
that says you've got permitted
activities you've got activities we're
going to control and you've got
prohibited activities
as part of the activities you're going
to control
provide for
um you don't need to call it a
dispensation we're controlling these
activities you need a consent from
council and here's the things that we're
going to take into account
and the subdivision development by law
has
has a good provision in it that says
when considering requests for a
dispensation in that case
um
regard shall be given to a number of
factors
in addition to what goes into the
subdivision development by law i would
suggest that
factors that council has regard to in
determining whether it consents to
certain activities
would be the activities taking uh
undertaken on the site that could
potentially introduce contaminants
into the stormwater system
and not listed in the other by-law would
be council will have regard to the
cultural impact of any discharges that
take place into the stormwater system
picking up on what courtney
had said earlier
now just
go to
my notes that i've got here
i just need to
find and i highlighted them in yellow so
i could find them quickly
listening to the richardson group
they make reference
to
cost sharing
where upgrades are required to
the system
now
in terms of the local government act
this council's policy
on development contributions
or financial contributions does not
provide for it
as far as i can see and therefore you've
put into the bible something that you
don't have authority to do
just to comment and observation
someone will tell me if i'm wrong on
that no doubt
um
drop me a jump
yeah just
through the gym and i think that was a
suggestion
from hwr that we should allow for
contributions
so it's not actually in there at the
moment right okay thank you thank you
um
[Music]
sorry i've just lost my place here well
while
um
we've interrupted you
yeah um
do you mind if i ask a question about
the
impermeable surfaces yes
no i don't mind before before we get too
far down the track um so um you're
possibly aware but the council's
done a reasonable amount of work in
recent years about understanding its
stormwater
capacity issues
and to provide a one and five-year level
of service
and upgrade the gore network it's
estimated cost 185 million dollars
which um you know the council obviously
has limited funding ability to
to implement that as as well as the the
practical
issues of doing 185 million dollars of
work
then you've got the district plan that
says
that you're allowed a certain amount of
impervious impervious surface
on your site
so in a situation where a developer
comes comes to the council
and
says i'm going to develop this site and
it's within the rules of the district
plan
in terms of impervious surfaces
um
if the council is aware of flooding
issues downstream of that site
it doesn't have the
money to upgrade the water downstream of
that site
and it knows that when this development
happens it will exacerbate that issue
irrespective of with its of if it's
within the
um
within the roles of the district plan
um
what would your proposed approach be
there
there's several answers which one is
very simple and the most simple one is
that the council rescind its earlier
resolution not to take financial
contributions under the district plan
and it only requires a resolution of
council and nothing else
it can then say to a developer as part
of the consenting process
you'll require if you want to go ahead
with this development we don't have the
money to do it and under the financial
contributions provisions of the district
plan now back in force
we require you to contribute to that
cost you've got the mechanism available
to you now
now i would suggest too that um
probably an update of the provisions of
what is in the current
long-term plan
is
needed but i think the framework is
already there there are other options
available but um
it's
the day's moving on
okay and so could the council claim that
whole cost
financial contributions the council in
the past has been pragmatic in its
approach
of of how it goes about it
and so there's a need to i guess
negotiate something there is fair and
reasonable
by applying the formula that's in the
contribution
and and
going from there council of course as
part of the resource consent process
is able to take into account the
environmental effects of the development
and if those effects
either individually or cumulatively uh
beyond a threshold it has the power to
turn the development notwithstanding
what benefits that development may bring
so i guess with the the
taking a financial contribution if it's
not sufficient to do the work that's
required
um
then until
the council finds that rest of that
money um you know assuming it was going
to come from other development in the
area then the downstream property owners
are going to suffer the
increased flooding work uh impacts until
that
the work's done and and that itself
gives rise to some um
legal issues in terms of liability
um for those contributing and and in
that regard there's a provision in the
draft by law
that actually relates to
public liability not
council consenting
i i acknowledge the the scale of what
you are looking at
um but the the
response required to it
uh needs to be multifaceted
if i can answer that mr and i i do
support the multi-faceted approach i
mean the
what mr however says is correct and that
i mean our current policy settings can
easily be changed
uh and they were
created in terms of financial
contributions when the council was in
less propitious economic times
so
that's a
discussion that's been loosely tossed
around from time to time about whether
it should be reviewed
the other thing of course is what is a
residential development versus a
commercial development we do currently
have the ability to take financial
contributions for commercial
developments over industrial
developments over 500 grand in value
but when you get a multiple
residential development
is that actually a
commercial development or is it it's at
the moment it's treated as residential
but it could well be that the review we
do
may need to revisit a definition of some
of those developments
now now that i've found my place if i
can move on to other matters and and the
the first relates to um
uh the process of people actually
seeking a dispensation from the bylaw
and
even if you have controlled activities
and say you need a consent
uh from the council you do not need to
set out on the bylaw how that consent
would be dealt with and the staff member
by title how they would um deal with it
um in in
simple terms
uh a consent is made to the chief
executive and he has the power of
delegation to staff a few so wishes
and it doesn't need to be dealt with in
the by-law it's dealt with as part of
the council's
consenting
delegations
manual i do however want to turn to the
council's discharge consent
because there's no numerous provisions
in the draft by law that says the
intent of the prohibited activities and
other things is to ensure that the
council's discharge
consent isn't contravened
and and
[Music]
council needs to take responsibility for
identifying what those activities are
that could contravene
its own consent and when i look at the
consent the first thing that comes up in
it is that it says that
after reasonable mixing and in the case
of the material river 100 meters
downstream of the discharge certain
standards must be met now that
immediately opens up a debate in the
bylaw context
as to whether you can lump the whole of
the discharge that's been measured 100
meters downstream back to a particular
single event or whether it's a
cumulative event
you should be managing what's going into
the system at the point of
discharge into the system
not what's happening sometimes three or
four four k away
and if i can give by way of example
the discharge if i can find the
condition
it talks about
[Music]
you aren't allowed to discharge into the
river rural storage and other matters
i would expect your bylaw to say you're
not allowed to discharge into our storm
water system raw sewage but it's not
there
and if you go through the list of other
things that are prohibited by the
consent
it's not a difficult process to actually
identify
a list of things that should not be
discharged into the council system and
it may well be that you have a standard
saying you are not allowed to discharge
sewer
storm water into the council system if
the e coli level is above a certain
amount
so it's the technical expertise of
council and its advisors that must be
informing what is in the by-law so the
individuals
landowners have certainty over whether
they can do it or not
because otherwise you're going to have a
situation of water's running across a
yard where a truck has been and it's got
diesel or something else and they're
suddenly getting a knock on the door
saying look we've measured 100 meters
downstream of our discharge and um
you've caused non-compliance and
therefore you're not compliant with the
by-law but a nonsense
it's
impossible to administer
sensibly
um
i think i've probably said enough i'm
happy to answer any other questions
there are other matters that are dealt
with in submission
but uh quote from someone else before
they appear to be relatively
straightforward and if as you go through
the process you need clarification i'm
happy to do so
but please i you do need to get further
information from
staff and and on legal issues and i
believe as a matter of natural justice i
should have the opportunity of
commenting on it
in a positive way to help you through
your process
without charge
or favor
uh yes keith i'd like to just ask this
question there
that is
the problem that everyone has
that
this hearing and before we got to this
point is there is no distinct line
and no person capable of actually coming
up with that
microscopic line of acceptance of
good stormwater to contaminated
stormwater
now
no one wants a distinct line
it wants
oh what's the terminology i'm looking
for but it it
yes
and to get
all the authorities
and all the landowners
and developers lined up
to accept that particular point is going
to be a challenge but that's what we're
here to achieve and how we do that
is probably not by bylaws but it's going
to be a group of people that gets
together to set that standard that's
um applicable to gore
and um
yeah whether we set the standard for new
zealand or not i don't know but um that
line that i'm talking about is
very very hard to achieve
thank you
through the chairman if i can just add
to that and to explain to the panel a
little bit more yes so in our in our
resource consent it
and i guess a lot of this has come from
sediment discharge into into felt and
crack and
um i guess the our resource consent
states that um
our discharge
cannot result in a conspicuous change in
color of the creek when you compare
upstream versus downstream so
effectively there's there's no as craig
was saying there's no clear number
or measurement as to what we need to to
meet um
because that changes depending on the
the water quality in the creek
at the time
um
and yeah i guess there's a process that
when you go through to to get a number
committed to but as as craigs pointed
out
it doesn't appear that an acceptable
number is out there at this point
um and i suspect that there'll be quite
a lot of
work and and cost in terms of um lab
analysis and research that would need to
go into that to establish that number um
no thanks for
uh that um
mr hovel
um
there's obviously a number of uh points
there um
and also follow-up question from craig
there so
and i dare say uh listening to the
information here yet as we
obviously will be getting a lot
more information in regard to some of
the uh matters have been raised today
and put through submissions and
from the layman's terms it is hard to
score a try when the goal posts keep
getting moved so
um
and we have to look at the fact that the
information and you know no clear number
as
have water manager says it's a difficult
situation to manage so hence we've got
some learner gentlemen and community
interesting
working group here
making submissions around this bylaw
so um i don't think there's any other
passive process i need to go through
other than thank the submitters
process forward from here is obviously
we will go
back taking on um
from the chair's point of view the
issues that were raised prior to
submissions made by mr hovel i'll
discuss them
with the
ceo
in relation to
that situation
submissions are made
and
deliberations but we still will come
back
to
further questions further information
gathering if required
and also
do we cover off the fact that
submissions have been made from the
submitters
for a chance a response into some of
that information
yes mr chairman look just to the next
steps and thank all submitters of some
really good points mate and some good
thought-provoking
aspects for us to consider
so
the next step for us will be to
develop a
proposed
and analyze the submissions both in
terms of
what's been presented in written form
and that includes those submissions or
submitters that didn't ask to be heard
along with the points that we've been
raised today which will be covered in
minutes taken of of of today's
proceedings by mrs jones at the head
table
then there will be some staff analysis
uh there probably will be some external
analysis provided by uh either or both
of our consultants our legal advisor
and the property group particularly
around the permeability and where they
can be dealt with in the district plan
definitely that there will come to be
some input from the property group in
that regard
and then back to the
hearings panel for
consideration about
whether
an initial cut i would
suggest is whether
they want to have a look at certain
aspects and embrace them
and then the question will arise for the
panel whether it goes
through another process of either select
consultation with submitters or whether
if there's a quite a substantive change
from the bylaw it may wash it may wish
to actually just put out the bill or
another draft for further consultation
because if it's substantively changed
people who may have thought i can live
with that
and didn't bother to put a submission
and
may may say gee i would actually like to
put into that so that's that's something
for the kit the committee or the panel
to consider
um
and then
if that's the case there will be a
further round uh for the hearing and
then ultimately um some recommendations
to go to the full council so there's a
bit of water to go on the bridge but i
think it'll be heavily dependent upon
the analysis we um
and our reflections to the panel
about what we believe
needs to be modified there's been some
really good points made some pragmatic
suggestions to
improve the
the effectiveness of the bylaw along
with and i can as an officer i can say i
completely agree with certainty everyone
wants certainty as to okay
what are the rules how does it work
affect me in this particular
circumstance
and remove uh the room for ambiguity
albeit it's a difficult area to actually
have crystal clear uncertainty excuse
the pump with water
so that mr chairman is probably a
summation of what we would do moving
forward first thing is the minutes and
then a staff report along with
advice
that those data vice staff report and
the advice received will be in the
public domain
the only qualification i'd make is that
if there is legal advice
it
may well be
retained uh under the auspices of legal
privilege but that's a qualified
statement of stage depending on what
sort of advice that is if it's a very
generic helpful advice to the process it
would be made available
uh julie noted um
the minutes are provided to the
submitters for
clarity and inaccuracies they they do
get a copy of those yeah
okay that's fine uh no well thanks for
that i'll close the panel there thank
you gentlemen for your input and ladies
and
the submissions that are made and we'll
be obviously notifying you in due course